et
[Musique]
les jb s'ennuie l'effet télé je ne les
intéresse plus à force de vivre sur la
terre petit à petit et sans s'en rendre
compte ils se sont mis à vieillir
[Musique]
tous les jours ils traînaient
lamentablement leur ennui et comme ils
ne trouvaient rien de spécial à faire
ils se préparaient des repas très
recherchée et ça donnait sans aucune
retenue à la gastronomie
à ce régime là vous pensez bien il
devint très rapidement gras et bouffi
[Musique]
voici de maigrir les malheureux faisait
de la culture physique et alors on les
vit on les vit non nous ne devrions pas
alors on vit triste et douloureux
spectacle on vit l'egypte s'est
autrefois si intelligente petites bêtes
se mettre à faire du vélo à ramer et à
poux et imaginez-vous comme de vulgaires
shadoks
or c'en était trop et les shadoks
prisonniers qui étaient assez doué de
naissance pour ce genre d'exercice
servait de moniteurs et en profiter pour
se venger un peu vous pensé oh là là
qu'elle est triste spectacle c'était là
les jb groupe est tombé
coupet
ils pompent est comme ça pendant toute
la matinée à midi le fais toyer et
l'après midi le suivait des traitements
appropriés
alors ça va pas il le criait gégène
alors on joue plus mais l'egypte y
réponde et qu'il travaillait ne renvoyez
chipé à grands coups et dans le derrière
à week-end vous ville un spectacle
c'était mais rien n'y faisait et puis le
pomper plus légers me vieillissaient
guily c est pour lui une fille c'est
officiel binya tant qu'à la fin ils
devaient encore plus vilain avec le
groupe barbe était pas mal planté qui
commençait alors poussé partout et les
pauvres petits
vous savez toujours pas quelle maladie
il avait attrapé
[Musique]
et